au mois de janvier a été sanglant
terrorisant et déstabilise même pour
impayés prouver comme l'afghanistan le
quotidien est devenu insupportable pour
les pénates rome date cela les abeilles
explosera peut encore aujourd'hui kaboul
s'est levé au son des sirènes à 5 heures
du matin
cette fois la cible et l académie
militaire onze soldats ont été tués
autant laisser câblo qui est en état d'
alerte maximale
on attend la prochaine bombe cet homme
exaspéré regardez ce qui arrive à notre
pays le gouvernement complètement perdu
le contrôle les forces en présence les
talibans idf ne font que gagner du temps
la colère des aboiements
les avants sont vraiment épuisés et
désespérés de ces attaques successives
et et ils l'expriment beaucoup plus sur
les réseaux sociaux que dans la vue
mais ce que disent de nombreux afghans
c'est que chaque matin quand ils sortent
de chez eux ne savent pas s'ils vont
rentrer le soir à lille
karl attaques d'aujourd'hui survient
alors que les afghans n'ont même pas
encore fini d'enterrer les morts du
carnage de samedi dans le quartier le
plus animé de kaboul cent trois
personnes ont été tuées
un massacre presque tous des civils
fauchés par une ambulance piégée bourg
et d'exploser
deux jours plus tôt c'était l'hôtel
intercontinental que l'horreur a frappé
22 personnes la plupart des étrangers
ont péri au terme d'une violente prise
d'otages quelques jours auparavant
cinq autres personnes sont mortes dans
les locaux de la mjc de chargers ont été
attaqués à djalal abad dans l'est du
pays c'est comme s'il n'y avait plus vu
sur en afghanistan de l'avis même du
service de renseignement et l'usiné de
comprendre tel qu amour puisse être
toujours possible il ya une
intensification des raids américains de
console demande de celui c'est pas une
heure de vengeance de réponse de ses
bouquets robin qui en multipliant ces
attaques mettent le gouvernement pour
plus en difficulté il n'ya pour le
moment aucune issue diplomatique en vue
il est hors de question de négocier avec
les talibans la donne a changé a déclaré
aujourd'hui le président dans notre
choix il a laissé entendre qu'une
victoire militaire est la seule option
possible
pourtant dix sept ans de guerre en
afghanistan auront jusqu'ici prouvé le
contraire
ou si thammarat altérer ce que
radio-canada horaire